hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the quarterfinals uh in a match
between hikaru nakamura and yanni
ponnachim uh so if you've
seen yesterday yesterday was a pretty
pretty crazy day uh there were a lot of
very decisive games and
a lot of great positions but in the end
of the match between
hikaru and nipple ended in a draw and
now they're playing the second match and
now if
either of them wins this one then they
go into the semi-final so
it's a very nice game this is the second
game of the second day the first game
nipple won also very nicely uh but now
uh this one uh this game is even nicer i
first thought about showing the first
one but then i decided i'm going to show
the second one
as it's uh well it's really just a
wonderful stuff
so without further ado uh let's check it
out and see what
we have here so he car with the white
pieces opens with e4
we have c5 by nipple going for the
sicilian defense with knight to f3
e6 and now d4 striking in the center
uh we have c captures knight captures
and now knight to c6 so this is all very
very standard the time amount of
variation of the sicilian
uh knight to c3 continuing development
and queen to c7 now
we have f4 by hikaru and now you want to
take away the b5 square from white's
knight so a6
now we have knight back to b3 avoiding
any unnecessary traits
uh and b5 now grabbing more space
preparing b4 in the future bishop to b7
knight is coming to f6 so
a very natural development for black
with bishop to d3
and bishop to b7 as planned we have
castles and
now d6 and here uh the most common move
for white is bishop to e3 but hikaru
actually played bishop to d2 here which
is not a new move it has been played
before
uh but i guess there's a uh well
there definitely is is a reason why you
play bishop to d2 i guess it's sort of a
way to maybe shift the bishop over to c3
at some point maybe if you play a3 move
the knight bishop c3 then grab hold of
this diagonal
could also be a mouse slip i don't know
uh but
it uh well it definitely helps uh to
throw nipple off his
preparation but okay we have knight to
f6 it's not a new move if you're
wondering
uh queen to f3 developing the queen
connecting rooks and now
bishop to e7 and there is one game in
the database where king the h1 was
played but here we have rook
8 to e1 and it is as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game so
car now has full development all of his
pieces are developed the rooks are very
nicely occupying the enf file
and nepo still has the finished
development but he starts with b4
so what do you do here and it's a very
tricky move to throw in
you're wondering okay why didn't you
castle why not uh develop the rook
i mean why you do this nipple uh and
here uh you have to go
knight to a uh sorry knights the a4 it
looks like a very ugly square for the
knight but this is what you have to do
and the problem is he car didn't do this
he carplayed knight to d1
and now there's a problem and it's not
easy to spot this problem unless you
will until you see it so here nipple
went a5
preparing a4 and there's no way to
prevent this you just have to continue
the game
he carl played knight to f2 and now a4
pushing the knight all the way back we
have knight to c1
and now you've lost the control of the
d4 square so now knight to d4
attacking hikaru's queen on f3 queen
back to d1
as the the the c2 pawn was attacked
twice so the queen and bishop now helped
defending it and d5 now of course uh you
have to play this this
is the sicilian dream uh you have to
bust open the center and now
both bishops come alive but for the
moment he carl closes the center he says
e5 your bishops will remain closed for
the moment
but now just knight to e4 and now with
these two knights
so excellently placed here on d4 and e4
uh
it's uh well it's a question what do you
do here uh it seems that
best is just to capture it even though
it only uh you know plays into black's
idea
black wants to open up the diagonals for
the bishops this diagonal and also this
bishop is coming to c5 to grab hold of
this diagonal
but there doesn't seem to be anything
better for example if knight captures
you can recapture and after
uh characters capture some captures yes
they a one white one upon but only
temporarily knight captures on c2 is
coming and then
it's just a very very good position for
black you're gonna castle bring the rook
over to d8
and the play and play on the queen side
so this is what would happen but it's uh
maybe the best uh hikaru had but he
covered played knight to e2
and now nepo goes on the attack knights
to f5
so again what do you play here uh we
have king to h1 by hikaru not allowing
any uh knight captures to
to come with check also getting away
from the this diagonal but
uh you're also stepping into this
diagonal so
you know you you win some you lose some
but now queen to b6 an extremely strong
move by nepo going after the knight on
f2 the knight is now attacked twice
so knight the h3 by hikaru
it's interesting what happens after
bishop captures an e4 for example d
captures and now knights the g3 uh it
still doesn't work because
here nipple just has e3 and this is
super strong the pawn is defended by the
knight and by the queen
so you have to eliminate this knight for
example but then just spawn captures and
again your rook is under attack you
cannot capture the pawn
uh not much to do here you can capture
on e7 but then f captures any one with
check uh and then rook or queen capture
sun f1 king captures here
and we ended this variation with black
being up a whole rook and of course in a
completely winning position
so instead after queen to b6 we have
knight to h3 by hikaru
but now uh nepo just continues the
onslaught uh bishop to h4 the rook uh
cannot move
and there really is no good way to
defend and what nepo really wants here
is for hikaru to play g3 but
then you open up this bishop's diagonal
and that's just game over
now you just play d4 open up the
bishop's diagonal prepare some very very
nasty discoveries here
and for example if bishop captures
bishop characters yes you have king the
g1
but now you just bring the bishop back
bishop to be bishop to e7 you're going
to bring the bishop here you have this
bishop here
and it's a very very difficult position
for white to play of course it
it is completely winning for black so g3
not an option after bishop to h4 we have
bishop back to c1 by
hikaru and now of course nepal just wins
material
bishop captures sunny one queen captures
uh in the now
finally nipple castles so i remember
when i said that anyappo could have
castled
he decided to play b4 and create some
complications and it immediately paid
off
that's that's a good chess right there
so knight to g3
hikaru offering trades here but now b3
uh trying to weaken uh white's position
on the queen side and also it will make
this
this bishop weak so here a captures we
have eight captures uh and
now uh we have knight the g5 hikaru has
to try something he brings the knight
into the attack
but now just knight knight after g3 with
check
h captures and b captures on c2
so again what do you play here uh
white's position is just terrible
there's not all that much you can play
here hikaru tries
f5 to start some sort of an attack if he
can get f6
in good things might happen but nipple
of course doesn't allow
it he plays e captures on f5 and after
rook captures on f5
uh it was in this position that hikaru
uh nakamura resigned in the game
uh without even uh waiting for nepal's
reply as the position is just
that terrible uh so i will
try and um uh well i'm gonna try for
your pleasure i will try to continue
this game in the
most uh entertaining way possible so one
way
i'm thinking this game could have ended
is of course rook to a1
makes sense as the queen and king are
still on the h file
and now there is no good move for white
if white tries something to create some
sort of a
counter attack here we just eliminate
the knight
rook captures on g5 and now this queen
captures on e6 and now
very interesting if rook to e5 for
example going after the queen you can
even sacrifice the queen here and it's
perfectly fine
queen captures you're gonna eliminate
the bishop with check
king to h2 and now you sacrifice the
rook rook to h1
uh to make the c1 check queen move come
with check so king h1
c1 queen and that's just it there's
nothing to be done for example king here
queen to h6 check black is up a rook you
have to go back with the king then rook
c8 rook c1 and
that's just it so really really
impressive stuff nepal not only wins
the first game but also the second game
in only 28 moves
with the black pieces which is
incredibly incredibly impressive
and it basically all started here when i
said after rook 81 this was a new move
in the position by hikaru
and yep could have just castled he could
have started you know rook to c8 just
continuing development but this b4 move
is what allowed him to create this
beautiful game
because you have to go you have to go to
the very ugly a4 square in order to
prevent
a5 and a4 and then white kind of white
definitely is
still in the game but with the movie car
played it was just
all straight downhill from there so very
very impressive stuff by nepo
which is not all that uh surprising as
he is the current leader of the
candidates tournament that is uh well
uh soon to be continued uh so uh like i
said after this uh
uh hikar resigned and now hikaru needs
to win game three and game four just to
get back into the match and to force tie
breaks we'll see uh what happens and if
he will be able to do it
uh so yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank um
uh well i would like to wish uh tommy
ace and a happy birthday as uh
his friend um i contributed in in his
honor so i hope you have a hope you have
a great one
uh uh brian plotnick brian plotnick uh i
would like to thank tara skarpyak
tal is the greatest and also a future
who with his contribution becomes the
top contributor of the channel
uh with his uh contribution of 2021
nano which uh sort of an equivalent to
ten thousand dollars
uh and i know some of you guys are
wondering but how come uh mystery is now
uh
only only uh 9.590 as
one bitcoin is now worth uh much more uh
well it's uh because
the uh this is what it was worth at the
time of the contribution so i know a lot
of you guys are confused about that but
that's how uh that's how it is uh
portrayed there
so congratulations to mr future who uh
decided to remain anonymous but he did
uh
ask if i could mention uh one one a
little sentence that uh
nano is like bitcoin but it is without
fees and it is instant in transactions
so uh there you have it if anyone is
interested
uh so uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh see you soon guys